hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I'm just checking in on you
see you now your works going your work
weeks going how are you how the people
doing down there in Cuba Dominican
Republic east coast of Florida huh
Hurricane Dorian is that what it is is
that what they're calling it
hurricane Dorian no is that like a
gender-neutral name and if they'd taken
it that far with political correctness
cuz I don't know nor name meaning let's
see what it this means Dorian is a
unisex who says I'm not progressive so
what is that that's dort Dorothea and
Nathaniel combined is that what it is
Dorothea no it's Ian it's Dorothy and
Ian combined that's what I'm guessing oh
it's it is a unisex given name of Greek
origin oh is that like the half horse
half guy thing except now it's half
horse half lady well why is the lady in
the Bell let's put her up front
let's have there let's have the guy be
the ass there we go that's progressive
that's how they're gonna start drawing
that thing no way cuz it's it's half a
goat I'm surprised PETA hasn't had a
problem with that in Crete the meaning
of the name Dorian is of Doris a
district of Greece orab Doris a
legendary Greek hero Doris was the
founder of Dorian the Dorian tribe and
the most likely origin of the Doris name
was the Greek word Doran meaning gift oh
there you go see that you you you think
you don't learn things when you listen
to a man who doesn't read other than
rock autobiographies quarterbacks from
the 70s autobiographies that's what I
read
that's what I'm bringing - why am i
yelling to you guys cuz I'm excited cuz
I'm still have not got over the fact
that I'm actually home I'm home and you
know what I got in one of our bathrooms
because nobody used it for months on end
we got we got all we got the black mold
the african-american mold sorry don't
offend anybody fits this is the the bad
kind right and it's just because of the
color and this this has nothing to do
with race before you get in trouble here
but I guess this is this is the McMorris
kind that you don't want to have in your
[ __ ] house so now I got it I got to
go over to [ __ ] Home Depot I gotta go
get the mask I got to get the gloves I
got a pour a cup of [ __ ] you know
bleach in there and then up in the tank
and then make sure and then you know
what I'm gonna do everything that they
[ __ ] say no matter how much I do what
they say I'm gonna get all these emails
from you guys going bill oh my god you
need to burn that [ __ ] bathroom down
there's no [ __ ] it's just just it's just
a little bit you know it's like all you
[ __ ] recreational cokehead users you
don't go out by an Eightball you walk by
you do a little bump off a [ __ ]
ironing board and then you know you
continue on you know you do your little
mashed potato dance whatever the [ __ ]
you kids student nowadays well what are
they hip dance huh the go-go I don't
mean I'm so not a dancer I don't even
[ __ ] know the name of dances the
running man that's the last name that I
knew and then for some reason there was
the the Harlem something or other which
I didn't under human the Harlem shake I
remember that and then it came back
again and it was something different it
was just white people acting like idiots
and videos I believe I don't know why I
don't know I'm not into that Internet
[ __ ] as I sit around you know those
those dumb fads yes bill the ones you
make fun of every podcast alright easy
all I know is college football starts
all right it starts this [ __ ]
Saturday Alabama Crimson Tide they're
playing Duke huh this is the dummies
versus the Smarties game well if you're
so [ __ ] smart
why can't you win a football game right
that's the stereotype of both schools is
that Duke is smart and that Alabama is a
bunch of mouth-breathing [ __ ] morons
and I I was too dumb to get into either
school so y'all all y'all seem smart to
me all right let's see who my LSU Tigers
are playing this year huh my LSU Tigers
I'm from Massachusetts and I've adopted
this team LSU football schedule let's
see who do we got oh Jesus we're
starting off with the powerhouse Georgia
Southern just when you didn't think
Georgia was south enough this is south
of Georgia people even Leonard Skynyrd
was scared when they went to this
[ __ ] campus then we can then we got
uh-oh what rank six we we're rank six
we got Texas Longhorns 10th how about
them coming back that program came back
it was scary there for a few years good
for them then we got n NW state I didn't
know what that is Northwestern State
North Wyoming North Walla Walla I have
no idea then we got Vanderbilt Nate
bargatze I'll take some money off of him
he's got too much pride
he's got more pride than brains I'm
gonna bet him on that game on win some
[ __ ] state cash we got Utah State
then we got Florida that's the first big
one on the 12th ah would you look at
this [ __ ] then we get into the SCC
Mississippi State the next week then you
got over and the Auburn tag is LSU
whether it's gonna be battle of mascots
then they got Alabama on the 9th will
they still be ranked 6th at that point
usually at that time of year Alabama's
ranked number one and one [ __ ] game
screws them over something [ __ ] them it
seems then we got Mississippi then we
got Arkansas and then we got Texas A&M
well believe it or not is part of the
SEC if you've been snooze in the last
couple of years that's a great [ __ ]
schedule not an easy schedule it's a
great schedule though
now I'm gonna listen all the [ __ ] Big
Ten people yeah
see see spoken we alright so anyways
let's talk about let's talk about movies
I finally went out and saw Quentin
Tarantino's eighth movie Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood
alright and you know they got that
website tomatoes up Rotten Tomatoes
alright well I'm gonna start my own here
all right old freckles thumbs up two
thumbs down I [ __ ] loved that movie
I [ __ ] loved that movie that was a
fastest two hours and 45 minutes of my
life when the dude came out you know and
he made a joke we were at the ArcLight
you know he came out he goes this is uh
Quentin Tarantino's movie Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood it stars Margot Robbie
and a bunch of other people and that was
in reference to ivory well I guess a
bunch of people were disappointed that
she wasn't in the movie more which I
thought she was in the movie a lot she
didn't say a lot but she conveyed a lot
you know I don't know but then I thought
about I was like you know what I
understand why so many women are
complaining because I think throughout
history in Hollywood you know I don't
know about you guys but personally I am
waiting for beautiful blond white women
to be represented positively in American
cinema I don't know I saw the trailer
and I was like this is a Brad Pitt
Leonardo DiCaprio movie I don't know
where the [ __ ] confusion was i'm not'
and by the way no spoiler alert I should
have said that early on everybody just
shut off my podcast I'm not gonna ruin
any other than to say that I [ __ ]
loved it and I've been having a great I
went with my lovely wife and we've been
you know throwing around all of our
theories and all of that [ __ ] my buddy
Dean's already seen it twice I got to
see it again cuz I was spending a lot of
time looking at the cars and there was
all these great classic hilarious
[ __ ] lines in it I absolutely [ __ ]
wire-to-wire loved loved that [ __ ]
movie and one of my favorite things one
time Quentin Tarantino he was talking
about making movies and people would say
oh he can't do this you can't do that
and he's like wait a minute
wait
I I can do whatever the [ __ ] I want and
those are the people those are the
people you want to go see their movies
those are the comedian's you want to see
I could say whatever the [ __ ] I want to
say you know [ __ ] jerk-offs anyway so
I guess there was some sort of scandal
about that I thought Margot Robbie
absolutely [ __ ] killed it in the
movie and I thought she was a major part
of it you know what she was conveying
the story that she was telling without
speaking I mean the skill set just to do
that was amazing so I don't know maybe
I'm talking about it too much but I
absolutely loved it
I give a giant pasty freckled thumbs up
way the [ __ ] up so you're thinking about
seeing it and believe me it flies by it
flies by I'd loved it
other than that I am still rehabbing
it's a rough transition here to go from
a movie that I loved with my my varicose
vein [ __ ] surgery or whatever I was
supposed to [ __ ] lay off it for seven
days and I was going a little [ __ ]
stir-crazy so I I just went down you
know I played a little bit of drums just
for a little bit it's my high hat like I
didn't think it was a big deal but I
guess I was tapping my leg and I bugged
it just a little bit just just a little
you know I sigh sound I sunk the little
kid in that Richard Pryor bit you know I
was I wasn't really run and running so I
kind of [ __ ] it up a little bit but uh
it seems to be healing up nicely
my leg was purple and now would say it's
a light purple with some disgusting
yellow and it looks like my whole leg
has jaundice pretty soon pretty soon
it's gonna be all healed up and you know
what for the first time in a long time I
can hit the street wearing my boy shorts
and that's all I wanted out of this
operation to be honest with you I really
did um no but thank you to the people
that worked on me
I feel better I know I [ __ ] up a
little bit I probably shouldn't be
saying this they'll use us against me in
a court of law well there's a true bill
that you went down and played drums some
reason the guys dressed like Matlock
actually talks like a guy who dresses
like Matlock
the Colonel Sanders look yeah so last
night I went and I went down to the
Laugh Factory
I did Jay Davis's birthday show happy
birthday to him and then I did Bryan
Callen show afterwards and uh been
trying out my new [ __ ] which I have to
do cuz the trailer for my new special
went out today it's on all my social
media it's coming out September 10th and
what I need you guys to do was is tell
everybody to watch this thing so that I
can continue you know living it
prolonging my adolescence by having this
silly job I had so much [ __ ] fun less
than I ain't been to the had been to the
Laugh Factory in a minute
I had a [ __ ] great time a lot of
funny people down there in front of me
and all that [ __ ] and and I've been
trying to do this thing that bit about
lesbians that the first time I did it
those two chicks [ __ ] screamed at me
walked out and then waited for me to
[ __ ] come out and then yelled at me
some more
and now I'm doing the bit and it's
killing all right
it's [ __ ] [ __ ] it's like it's a
new bit I'm working it out all right I'm
gonna find the funny you [ __ ] [ __ ]
so I think I found the funny and I don't
tell you all my subjects but uh I just
had a great time last night and of
course I said it perfectly the first
show and then you come up on the second
show trying to remember how you said it
and then you [ __ ] up cuz you're not in
the moment again and the whole thing
goes to [ __ ] but it was definitely a
definitely a good night banged out two
shows and I got to get ready because I
got Vegas coming up next week
I think that's September 6 Friday night
and then I'm hanging around because I'm
gonna go see Elton John because he's
honest is you know three-year farewell
tour I know it's kind of funny but
eventually the guy has a lot of fans I
mean it's taking this guy probably half
a decade to say goodbye to everybody and
I want to make sure that I see him you
know see the whole thing going with the
lovely Nia I think Dean might be going
to we're gonna have a [ __ ] great
I'm so I'm looking forward to that but I
gotta make sure that I don't bomb with
my new [ __ ] well actually my special
won't be out yet but I did my other hour
my last hour the last time I was there
so I gotta make sure I got off all kinds
of all kinds of new [ __ ] so it should be
a good time that's September 6th and and
that's it and with that let's get on
with the podcast here let's talk about
let's talk about hurricane that
hurricane Dorian Google News here you
can track its path let's check out my
geography here these poor [ __ ] people
man the balls it takes to live where all
of these people live if you actually
have like if you actually have the money
to get the [ __ ] out of there it really
says a lot about Florida you know I get
people in Cuba I mean you're not allowed
to leave Dominican Republic Haiti all
these [ __ ] places I mean it's at
Porto Rico you're on an island it's hard
to get the [ __ ] out of there I mean you
get in a car eventually get to the ocean
yes bill we understand what an island is
you're in Florida I mean you just you
can just start [ __ ] driving you can
get the [ __ ] out of there right so here
it is they're projecting it today it
seems to be it's just north of Puerto
Rico and this saying well actually no
now it's north of [ __ ] to the
Dominican Republic well that's how it
goes it goes Puerto Rico Dominican
Republic Haiti Cuba and Jamaica's down
south there so anyway the they're
projecting that it's going to hit
Florida
September 2nd or September 3rd Jesus
couldn't [ __ ] T I mean every year you
got to deal with that [ __ ] now every
[ __ ] year was it always like that
every [ __ ] year the Rolling Stones
moved their Miami Gardens concert up to
get ahead of Hurricane Dorian god bless
them you know we want to get down there
and make sure we don't have to take your
money off your dead drowning carcass we
got to get down there get down there
we're gonna get your money give
one last [ __ ] show and that Royd
everybody be safe try to stay dry
thank you for your money go [ __ ]
yourselves and then they get on them and
they get the [ __ ] out of there nobody
does the road like the Rolling Stones
they even know when a some of you were
gonna die and then they [ __ ] get in
there and they get your [ __ ] money
beforehand
now that's see now that's how you do the
[ __ ] Road Trump cancels Poland trip
is hurricane bears down on Florida does
he realize we're [ __ ] Poland is he
can fly right by it
oh he cares about Florida oh sorry about
that I wonder if a [ __ ] hurricane was
hit in LA probably reload relocate the
pole that he wouldn't give a [ __ ] about
us out here that son of a [ __ ]
many genes influence same-sex sexuality
not a single gay gene this is unwanted
and the [ __ ] are we doing why do we need
to know that are they gonna make you
know gay robots and straight robots I'm
telling you guys are all out of your
[ __ ] mind anybody went on that
ancestry.com you just gave your [ __ ]
DNA to the internet are you out of your
[ __ ] minds like where where can that
go in a good place
I know they could a can see if you're
susceptible to this and whatever it's
gonna land in the wrong [ __ ] hands
but whatever that's what you want to do
I'm just here to recommend movies and
talk about football schedules that
that's all I'm trying to do here I'm not
trying to be anything beyond what I am
you know last night when I did that show
somebody hadn't seen in a while sent me
a picture and was like dude I was in the
crowd didn't have time to say hello
great set and he took a picture of me oh
my god what gravity is doing to me it's
just [ __ ] Mike [ __ ] I already put
on her how much I put on since the movie
I had the audacity to wear a t-shirt
last night I'm in my 50s you don't wear
a [ __ ] t-shirt you got to put another
sure it over yourself so I don't know
whatever I'm gonna blame my leg the
second this is over I'm gonna start
working out again like the soccer mom
workout that I do because I'm too
[ __ ] old to do anything else my
shoulders are too [ __ ] up to lift
weights anymore so now I got to do like
like my workouts now I have like mats I
do like yoga and [ __ ] I get on the
elliptical I just had to admit that I
was old you know I'll tell you who's
aging in dog years there's all those
[ __ ] lunatics they look great but
those lunatics who are doing Crossfit
every time I Drive by you know they
always have the [ __ ] you know it's
such a voyeuristic workout like look at
us we're working out right or maybe it's
green they don't want to waste all that
energy with treadmills but I think it
really is like think that you're just
screaming for attention so they got the
garage door up and you look in and I
swear to god half at least 60% of the
[ __ ] half to 60% of time I Drive by I
just see them doing something and I just
wince I know that's because I'm [ __ ]
old but like they're gonna be old
someday too and you know just blowing
out your [ __ ] joints this is
something I learned you know this is
obvious but I wasn't thinking about it
yet you need your knees and your
shoulders for your entire life
you know I don't know there's two things
that I would invest in as far as just
sort of random things whoever the people
are that work on joints and [ __ ] like
that
the osteoporosis doctors what'd he call
those [ __ ] joint doctors all right I
would invest in that and I would pull my
money out of weed because I think it's
gonna be over already saturated and know
that I don't have any idea about any
what's going on in any of these markets
just know that as I'm telling this to
you I would take my money out of weed
man and then I would stick it in any
sort of company that is working on the
next level tattoo removal doohickey that
was out there driving down the [ __ ] it's
you know I was out there man I was
I've been down that [ __ ] Street I was
out there and I looked over and there
was this beautiful woman and she just
had tattoos that started on her arm went
up to his shoulder up to her neck and
all on the side of her face and it was
like she had a bunch of leaps they
weren't filled in yet so I imagine the
tattoo wasn't finished and she's
eventually going to do a bunch of other
[ __ ] but Jesus Christ with the face
[ __ ] tattoos you know I actually went
down a rabbit hole and I somehow was
looking up all this mumble rap [ __ ]
which is hilarious because it had the
history of mumble rap it started off
with this guy they were making fun of
his haircut and like it looked like the
same haircut Brian Jones had in the
Rolling Stones that pageboy haircut then
he had like glasses on and he was
[ __ ] seem to be [ __ ] wasted and he
was just saying hey why y'all making fun
of my haircut just want to tell you I
don't give a [ __ ] uh-huh like that was
the video and I was just like wow that
guy needs [ __ ] rehab that guy needs
rehab like I need sit-ups hey let me
tell you so I was like I was another
mumble rap guy I want to say he had a
face tattoo I can't keep it [ __ ]
straight I don't I don't want I don't I
don't know things right so I [ __ ] I
go online and I just look up mumble rap
and then they had this really cool video
it's a history of mumble rap and what
was funny was I ended up downloading
like half the songs couldn't understand
what the [ __ ] they was saying not that
some of them they weren't really
mumbling I didn't think they were I this
is me actually getting transported
finally musically from like I don't know
how long ago until I think somewhere
along the line I don't know like some of
12 years ago I just kind of lost it as
far as like even knowing what it was
even remotely [ __ ] popular so now I'm
like about three years behind so I
downloaded the amigo
was bad in boo she [ __ ] love that
didn't have difficulty understand what
they what they were saying it's just you
know some of the references I obviously
didn't get and then I downloaded a 21
savage no heart that was a little more
mumbly you know we've all been there you
know who hasn't had a little codeine
with their [ __ ] breakfast but uh yeah
so I was actually I got I went down this
rabbit hole reading up on all of this
[ __ ] not reading up I was watching
videos Bill you don't read that's right
I wasn't and I came across this these
two [ __ ] young kids and they were
saying they were saying biggie smalls
was overrated and I was like wow shots
fired
dad hearing that was right up there
where I when I saw beware of mr. Baker
that documentary on Ginger Baker and he
said he trashed John Bonham I don't know
where the guy you know doing the
documentary was like going hey man uh
what do you think about John Bonham
because John Bonham couldn't swing a
sack of [ __ ] I almost fell out of my
chair I've never heard anybody trash him
oh wait a minute Keith Richards did what
am I talking about Keith Richards called
him a runaway 18-wheeler or something
I'm literally sitting here I just moved
my [ __ ] recorder now I'm wrapped all
up in the wires I don't know how much
easier I can make this [ __ ] on myself
and then ah then it drops then it drops
to the [ __ ] ground come on bill what
are you gonna get it together oh you
know what it is the microphone got all
to let it dangle all right let me do the
uh let me do the reeds here I apologize
how scatterbrain this [ __ ] thing is
I'm just freaking out that my specials
coming out I just want it to come out
and people to like it and people who
hate it to hate it and then just get
past it and move on with my [ __ ] life
you know cuz I mean that thing it's
locked it's coming out
and you know and I always go whenever
whenever my special comes out I just go
I you know I just go offline for a
little bit and then when I come back
people are talking about other [ __ ]
they're upset about other things and
they've just [ __ ] moved on from
whatever the [ __ ] they were gonna say
about my [ __ ] cuz III you know I don't
need the feedback it's it's too late
it's already out there what am I going
to fix it
alright Hilux everybody pass Hilux sweet
man Hilux sleep it's built Hilux sleep
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete and they use the
answers to match your body type and
sleep preference to the perfect mattress
whether you're in a side or whether
you're a side sleeper a hot sleeper
roast like a plush or a firm bed with
helix there's no more guessing or
compromising can you imagine if you met
the most beautiful woman in the world
right this is always the scenario with
guys most beautiful in the world
everything was perfect but when she
slept she just like soaked the [ __ ]
bed to the point that gradually
somewhere around 2:30 2:45 in the
morning like the sheets underneath you
started to get wet and you started to
get cold you would wake up shivering
every night as she sat there sort of
like you know in her REM sleep gorgeous
but like your [ __ ] eyeballs going
back and forth would you do it but she's
a sweetheart
you know but she also is needy like is
it okay if I sleep down at all no I
can't help it and she's so beautiful
that you just given but every night at a
quarter to three in the morning you just
[ __ ] sitting there and you're looking
at her and you're shivering right and he
can't grab the [ __ ] any of the blankets
or anything off the bed cuz they're all
[ __ ] soaking wet too right now you
got to go in the bathroom you got to put
on like a [ __ ] bathrobe she kind of
wakes up a little bit
Oh what are you doing what was i
sweating again
and they just gotta be like yeah yeah it
but it's alright we'll come back to bed
you know I don't like bein the sweaty
bed by myself and you have to [ __ ]
make that choice you think as a man a
weak man you could ever block out her
other world beauty how long would it
take you this is this is my question for
you how long would it take you before
you had you had had it all right and one
of those days you were just like I'm
[ __ ] I mean one of those days you
just go to bed with like I don't some
sort of waterproof clothes on well they
need to sleep through the night and I
know you got to you got to take it one
last night her gross [ __ ] night sweat
so can you Jam jams then you'd have to
slip out of bed why do you got to do it
that way why can't you just break up
with her just wake up the next morning
you know you don't even shower you just
have this ring of salt all over your
body from her this is really gross
whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper like a plush or firm bed with
helix there's no more guessing or
compromising just go to helix sleep calm
slash bar take their two-minute sleep
quiz if you're a dummy like me it
probably takes three minutes there and
they'll match you to a mattress that
will keep you the that will give you the
best sleep you've had in your life four
couples helix can even slip up the
mattress split up the mattress sorry
down the middle providing individual
support needs and feel preferences for
each side well do you got a little dam
in the middle for a hot sleeper to keep
the other person dry you know get the AC
on during the summertime I mean Jesus
Christ you could catch a pneumonia helix
sleep was even awarded the number one
best overall mattress pick of 2019 by GQ
& Wired magazine I didn't know GQ review
mattresses I'm just there was all suits
and cigars and shits CNN and CNN called
it the most comfortable mattress they've
ever slept on well I'll tell you when
they were sleeping on that during the
last election
[Applause]
they have that was for the red states
they have a 10 year warranty and you get
to try it out for a hundred nights
risk-free right now HELOCs helix is
offering $125 of mattress orders for our
listeners get up to $125 at helix sleep
off at helix sleep comm / / that's
HELOCs sleep dot-com / BER for $125 off
your mattress order comm / / heli79 a
clause help out some of these public
school teachers and maybe this can be a
thing maybe this will be maybe this will
be my cause that eventually the cause
fades into the background and it becomes
more about me you know like when Sally
Struthers used to just [ __ ] walk by
those starving kids and she had you know
remember all those bits people used to
do was she had all the makeup on and all
the hair was all teased I'm [ __ ] with
you
she's a saint she went over there and
she helped people out what's a better
example I don't know I'll probably be
the be the best example of self involved
as I am by the way what I liked about
some of that mumble rap is I don't need
to know what the [ __ ] they're talking
about as long as it as long as the track
sounds good and what I liked was on one
of those the hi-hat it was that was
playing sixteenth notes in the beginning
it was a little [ __ ] thirty-second
notes bursts this is just drummers and
then sixteenth notes and then at the end
of two it was like a triplet and then
you go right back to sixteenth notes
which was you know and it was a
syncopated beat to where the bass drum
was on the end of two in the end of
three if I lost to yet I really enjoyed
the [ __ ] challenge of that because I
never I never would think to play
something like that so that's what I've
always liked about you know I guess rap
music is I've always listened to the
[ __ ] beats first and then listen to
what the person was saying and I got a
meant a lot of them lose me because all
they're doing is just bragging about all
the [ __ ] that they have and
it's like I get it she got a lot of
stuff but I like the story tell us which
is why I always love biggie cuz I felt
like his his his raps were like movies I
could like see the whole [ __ ] thing I
like that's what I liked about Richard
Pryor like I go back and listen to his
albums I listen to as a kid I know what
everybody in that joke looks like I
still have it in my head and sometimes
when I listen when I haven't heard in a
while and I listen to it and it starts
playing in my head like an old episode
of TV I have to remind myself like wait
a minute like that I just this just came
into my head because of what he was
saying that's how good this guy's so
that's what blew me away when those
people were saying that he wasn't that
good but I also understand that because
every generation has to do that right
they got to slay the people whatever
they say I would just say but you got to
be going pretty hard to say that that
guy wasn't was overrated alright and
with that and with that okay that's the
podcast sorry about either was really
disjointed this time I just freaking the
[ __ ] out I hope you guys like the
special I can tell you this it's the
best-looking one I ever did Mike binder
absolutely killed it he's the guy who
directed it and I got to know him a long
time ago when I was doing this movie
called black or white with Kevin Costner
and we have remained friends ever since
it's one of my favorite people in this
business and like I knew he was gonna do
a good job when we first talked about it
I should I got to have him on the
podcast to talk about how this whole
thing came together but um even if
people don't like my jokes just [ __ ]
hit mute and just see how he put the
thing together it's absolutely gorgeous
I don't think I've ever said that about
a stand-up special but it's [ __ ]
gorgeous despite the fact that I'm in
the middle of it alright so that's it
tell everybody September 10th come on
man I need you guys you got to be there
for me make it a safe comedy space for
me by the way congratulations to
Sebastian for [ __ ] crushing it on one
of the iconic stand-up gigs you can have
the MTV Music Awards don't listen to
that [ __ ] that people wrote
because he crushed it on that and the
initial feedback was 100% positive and
then one person has a problem with it
and then that gets that's the one that
everybody latches on to he absolutely
killed it and I'm so happy for him
continued to success to him and speaking
of him and he's gonna he's in the kill
the Irish move kill the Irishman movie
with Martin Scorsese and and that's it
don't listen [ __ ] nine people [ __ ]
moaning and complaining and that becomes
the story but that that is the story
because that's enough people that's all
you need and then everybody starts
paying attention he [ __ ] killed it so
that's it have a great weekend you [ __ ]
and listen to the music and here's the
greatest hits Thursday afternoon just
before Friday Monday morning podcasts
from last year five years ago I don't
know how he does it alright that's it
thank you for listening September 10th
paper tiger on net
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what's going on its go burn it's the
Monday morning podcast for August 29th
2011 and this is a very special podcast
because I think the first time in my
podcasting history going back to June of
2007 back to Robert Kelly's apartment
where it all began
that fateful day when he set up my
podcast and I did my first podcast
albeit was only a twenty second podcast
it was still a podcast this is the first
time in history if I've ever been
stranded I am stranded because I don't
know if you guys heard there was a
hurricane I I can see how you might have
missed it you might have been watching
lifetime for the last 36 [ __ ] hours
yeah I'm stranded right now I am on a
piece of driftwood and fortunately I had
my computer bag and a generator so I'll
be hand cranking it throughout this
podcast but I'm okay I have on some
mittens and some Kevlar no I'm [ __ ]
I'm in this hotel you know what they did
they basically they scared the [ __ ] out
of everybody Christ you cut that [ __ ]
out of it they they scared the living
that what the [ __ ] is with the Weather
Channel what's the deal Louie would you
you know you can't you can't shout fire
in a crowded movie theater but evidently
you can have your own channel and tell
everybody that they're gonna [ __ ] die
drown or get crushed by a tree for three
[ __ ] days straight and screw up who
the [ __ ] got the heavy feet up there
it's gotta be kids you know what's the
last time you saw a graceful child you
know they're so used to it's so new to
running they've only been doing it for
like four years just stomping all over
the place with their brand-new spinal
cord nothing hurts they just run around
immune to anything Jesus Christ anybody
ever done that you know when they do
that when they they film joggers and
slow motion how much their calves are
[ __ ] you know shaking and the impact
of it I bet little kids it's even worse
you know they just come straight down on
their foot there's no
all know nothing anyways what the hell
am i talk about these people on the
Weather Channel that's unbelievable
three [ __ ] days this to talking it's
gonna be the worst storm the East Coast
has ever seen
I had six shows six shows this weekend
at the stress factory I only got to do
three of them because these [ __ ]
[ __ ] got everybody so goddamn scared
you know that's just unbelievable what
happens what happens it's always slams
into the south you know where it
deserves to be those inbred sons of
[ __ ] down they're all [ __ ] related
that's it's God God's doing it to you oh
Jesus right he sends it in there and
then a hit and he [ __ ] swoops away a
couple people in the Carolinas and by
the time it comes up here it really
doesn't do anything a couple of trees
fall down who the water's up to my
ankles a couple of basements get flooded
what the [ __ ] really happens Jesus
Christ they cancelled all the flights
for like two three days so now here I am
stuck in New Jersey
I have no goddamn shows and I can't get
out of here until Tuesday I don't know
what I'm gonna do it's Sunday night I'm
sitting in this [ __ ] hotel room
thanks to the goddamn Weather Channel I
swear to god 40 guys with chainsaws
could clean up all of New Jersey there's
really no problem and they sat there
saying that though it's comin right at
New Jersey scaring the [ __ ] out of these
people everybody going down to the
supermarket buying gallons of milk what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do with that
gallon of milk how does that help you in
a flood other than drag you under you
are you gonna dump two gallons of milk
out and use that as like a flotation
device you can duct tape to your back
what are you gonna do with your milk sir
your milk and your eggs what are you
gonna do can you imagine the amount of
sore utters out there because of this
[ __ ] storm huh the amount of chicken
sphincters that are [ __ ] raw
from laying all those goddamn eggs I
don't know where the eggs come they
don't come out of the ass where they
come out of the chicken [ __ ] is that
where it comes out of now you freak who
goes to bestiality calm and can answer
that one don't even lie to me that you
went to veterinarian school cuz I'm not
buying it if you went to that school
you're too smart to listen to this
podcast alright so if you know the
answer to that that means you have
[ __ ] chickens on a regular basis and
I don't want to hear otherwise alright
so go back out to the coop and have a
good time you [ __ ] weirdo oh god I am
in a mood I'm in a [ __ ] mood yeah they
canceled my flight and somehow I was
able to get I actually got a window seat
which is good you know Jesus Christ I
got I got to get my own helicopter
that's what I want a helicopter
helicopter that leads to a jet that's
what I want now I'll rent the helicopter
and it lands on every hotel or on top of
the comedy club the second I'm done and
I walk up into the attic of the comedy
club I jump on it bump up up up up up up
up up up up when I fly away and then I
landed some private airport and then I I
get on a private jet and then they take
that [ __ ] that they give you right
before they remove your an a your your
appendix you know some sort of gas they
knock me out and then next thing I know
they're just nudging me mister peres
we've landed in California that's how I
want to [ __ ] travel and I don't give
a [ __ ] what it does to the ozone layer
and I don't give a [ __ ] how much of an
arrogant ass it makes me I don't give a
[ __ ] how much I won't be able to relate
to my crowd because my life is that
awesome I don't care if my numbers
slowly back go go back down again I want
to go home I haven't been home remember
last week when I was talking about work
walk working in Nashville justic
remember that never meanin no harm I
don't mean no harm [ __ ] I'm just [ __ ]
stupid yeah I'm still I'm still on the
[ __ ] Road I went from Nashville
Wednesday I flew to Nashville then I did
showst
what was it Thursday I don't know I
don't remember I'm seeing double right I
have no [ __ ] idea
oh no wait oh I Wednesday and then I did
shows Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday I
flew to New York I ran my Letterman set
right in front of [ __ ] these New
Zealand water polo team the night before
of course it ate its balls then I went
on the Letterman Show right when it
counted I [ __ ] delivered you know
[ __ ] up in the end thought he was
going for another handshake I was like
I'll oblige and he was like no I don't
think so I was like hey it's your show
other than that I thought it was pretty
smooth if I do say so myself
so I got that out of the way then I had
two days to hang in New York and then I
came down to New Jersey and I'm like
this is gonna be great I got the
pressure a Letterman off me that's off
my [ __ ] back and now what now what do
I do I get to go to one of my favorite
clubs in the country the stress factory
I was already talking to Vinnie brand
the club owner he's got a boat we were
going to go out on his boat on Sunday
everything was gonna be great all the
shows were [ __ ] sold out had a great
time and then what happens these [ __ ]
nerds on the Weather Channel what do
they do they turn out all the lights in
this studio and they put a flashlight
under their chin and just start scaring
the living [ __ ] out of people and you
know what kills me is every [ __ ] time
people buy into it I was joking about it
all weekend I'm like nothing's gonna
happen I am in my hotel room I don't
even have a [ __ ] Snickers bar
nothing's gonna happen you're gonna be
fine all these people going out gather
enough [ __ ] food for what people do
you realize how long you can go without
food food is no big deal you need water
that's what the [ __ ] you need that's
what you need I'm actually looking here
on who gives a [ __ ] calm how long can a
person serve
five without food and water basically it
depends on a number of factors such as
body weight genetic variations other
health considerations whether you're a
[ __ ] or not most importantly the
presence or absence of dehydration as
long as you got water people you can
basically go forty six to about seventy
three days without without food then
that was based on ten individuals who
died on a hunger strike and they all
died between forty six days and 73 days
as long as they drank water if you don't
have water
I believe you're dead in about three
days all right so enough with the
[ __ ] milk and eggs all these soccer
moms now for the next [ __ ] three
weeks who wants who wants cereal who
wants the what you have in cereal and
you having an omelet
this isn't gonna go to waste these
[ __ ] people telling you to fill up
your goddamn bathtub full of full full
of water just in case jesus [ __ ]
christ
I'd rather die then drink out of my
bathtub all right I wash my [ __ ] dog
in there not drinking out of that thing
okay just stick my head out the window
and drink the raindrops I think those
windows be cleaner then the goddamn tub
that I wash my dog in and then hit with
chemicals left stomach cancer by the
time the [ __ ] rescue boat comes you
just get water
everybody get water get yourself a
couple of [ __ ] zagnut bars and then
go down go down go down to a goddamn
[ __ ] 7-eleven and go buy a eight
dollar poncho you're fine you're in a
house you're fine
[ __ ] people the weather Chino much
they cost me half my goddamn gig money
we could have had shows we could add
show Saturday night it was raining hard
Saturday night it could have done both
shows everybody could have got their
[ __ ] laughs everybody goes home and
then at night whoo girlie boogly
the [ __ ] hurricane ow hurricanes come
through the Northeast it's like it's
like an old prizefighter by the time it
comes to us it's all [ __ ] punch-drunk
and people have no business standing out
in it because they should have got
knocked out have no [ __ ] problem then
they just sit there laughing at it all
right
that's what it is that's what a
hurricane is in the Northeast if you
know when it's down south its Cassius
Clay
right before he becomes Muhammad Ali by
the time it gets up to Jersey in New
York it's [ __ ] Ali when he fought
Larry Holmes every [ __ ] time yet these
people they all run out the Weather
Channel how long you guys you guys think
Fox News lives to you or CNN depending
on what side of the political fence
you're on you want it you want to see
some lies put on the Weather Channel
anytime there's a storm scaring the [ __ ]
out of you every time there's gonna be
it's gonna be four to six inches holy
[ __ ] that's almost up to my calves how
will I ever get to where the food is
four to six inches Jesus Christ who are
they talking to 80 year olds even then
you know eight-year-old people they'll
be fine
your are they're already wearing a
sweater they're dress for a blizzard
year-round does anybody who work for The
Weather Channel
does anybody who listen to my podcast
can you please tell me well who's behind
yeah I think the supermarkets are behind
that right
Ralph's Shahs Gelson's [ __ ] Whole
Foods all of them that's their paola you
know with the big-time corporations they
wait for the political elections that's
when they start throwing their money
around and start calling up a truck full
of hookers to go blow some bible belt
and douche bag right I'm married I got
five kids I love my wife and I love
jay-z support the troops right then what
do they do they throw a big pile of
money at them have two three [ __ ] drop
to their knees the next what next what
happens
next huh he comes on his blue blazer
that's what happens everybody goes all
over his red tie and then he goes out
Jesus Christ all right you got me
you own me you got video of it just tell
me what you want me to do I will pass
any bill you want me to pass for the
love of God don't let my wife see that
that's basically how that works well
let's stay on track here okay the
[ __ ] weather does anybody listen my
podcast work
did they ever work can you give me any
sort of anonymous behind the [ __ ]
scenes over there why every time it's
just gonna rain do they scare the living
[ __ ] out of us why is that you know how
often are they right it always is it's
always downgraded to a tropical storm by
the time it comes here someone was
telling me the entire East Coast the way
it's shaped that's from years of
hurricanes comes right into Florida and
Georgia South Carolina gives it a nice
[ __ ] uppercut to their southern balls
and then slows the [ __ ] down right over
the Carolina Virginia you know then what
time it hits DC Barack Obama's out on
the porch drying off his nuts with those
nice win that nice hurricane win right
Jesus I don't know I'm talking but I
just want to [ __ ] go home I was
actually thinking you know when you you
know when you [ __ ] up in life you know
like God if I could just go back 48
hours Howard do this differently there's
an Avis in the lobby of my Jesus as a
call back from this time we left this
comedian he was always late we had a car
service to the airport we were so sick
of waiting for him we were gonna miss
our flight
we just took off without him we said
[ __ ] him and we got half halfway to the
airport he calls up all pissed off so
Joe where the [ __ ] were you where the
[ __ ] were you like do we waiting for you
20 minutes you didn't show up and he's
like I was in the lobby
and that became the catchphrase for the
rest of the tour I was in the lobby
any time you [ __ ] up and people were
calling it calling you on some [ __ ] you
went over your time no I didn't yes you
did I was in the lobby oh and it made us
laugh I don't know if it made you laugh
I don't give a [ __ ] but he expected from
me I'm stranded I feel like I'm being
held hostage and my captors forgot about
me you know or maybe it was just all a
practical joke I have no idea
so whatever here I sit you know is
anything sadder than a stranded comedian
with no shows to do they got a 24-hour
gym downstairs I haven't used it I've
been talking to you guys about all the
way to eat the way to lose weight I
haven't been doing it
dummy pizzas I had fish and chips today
at [ __ ] hamburgers yeah this is all
during hurricane big bad Hurricane Irene
[ __ ] overrated
so I'm sitting here I realized you know
tomorrow I'm like finally I'm getting
the [ __ ] out of here go home could see
my girl I can see my dog right you can
have a good [ __ ] time
you know can cruise around in my hybrid
[Music]
that's what I was looking forward to
doing and all of a sudden I realized
that was stranded here so what do I do
do I handle it like a man or do I start
cursing like a little [ __ ] you know
what the answer is so I want something
done having my [ __ ] temper tantrum
excuse me
is the fish and chips I say alright I'm
gonna rent a [ __ ] rent a movie here
in the hotel
so I go to rent a movie it's called
catching hell it's a documentary about
the guy with the glasses who was at the
Cubs game who reached up for that foul
ball that Moises Alou was allegedly
going to catch
so I hid the info to watch the trailer
and they're talking about they got this
guy on there going and says how he
worked for Sports Illustrated and his
assignment was to find this guy whatever
the [ __ ] his name was Steve mizerock I
don't know I'm not from Chicago so I
don't give a [ __ ] I don't know what his
name is
all right his as he goes my assignment
was to find this guy and he goes my
heart sank
you know because I actually fell for
this guy I didn't want to go see him and
I said to my editor why can't we just
leave this guy alone can't we just leave
the guy alone he goes no go find him and
then they start showing the highlights
of this dude and for those who don't
know the play basically the Cubs have
won the World Series since 1908 you know
they're a game away from going there
five outs away from going to the [ __ ]
World Series sorry to all the Cub fans
just hit [ __ ] mute for the next ten
minutes they got the five outs away so
some dude right left-handed batter hits
a slicing foul down the left-field line
it's right there and the Cubs left
fielder Moises Alou he's got a chance to
make a play and all the all these fans
reach up to grab the ball but the it
just hits one guy and Moises Alou flips
out because he doesn't catch it and he
sort of yells towards the fans like what
the [ __ ] I could have caught that and
then after that the wheels start falling
off but they got a double play ball
Gonzalez could have made it but he
booted it man forced in and they let up
eight runs they lose the game and then
they lose Game seven and then everybody
wants to murder this [ __ ] kid so this
guy is basically sold that they're gonna
basically interview the guy as far as I
could [ __ ] tell I'm like Jesus Christ
that's fascinating I let me watch this
God God knows that God let me watch this
movie alright so I go to order it and it
doesn't allow me to so I got a call
downstairs to have the you know I don't
know what somebody had kids or something
they didn't want to rent a porno so I to
get that you know switched over so I
could actually be an adult and pick out
a movie so I watch this [ __ ] thing
all right about the Cubs
about their history about their curse
about this poor bastard they got used as
the scapegoat this is what I was sold
this is the bill of goods I was sold
okay after 36 hours of being lied to by
the [ __ ] Weather Channel I want some
truth in my life
this is what you're telling me this
thing is about this is how you're
advertising and I want to see it do you
know what the first 15 minutes of that
movie was it was taking me through the
Red Sox in 1986 as they excruciatingly
ly slowly replayed the Bill Buckner
incident and I'm sitting there watching
and all of a sudden I'm looking at Bill
Buckner I'm like what did I order the
wrong [ __ ] thing I don't want to see
this [ __ ] do you understand this is like
my baseball 9/11 I don't ever want you
know that like the ten-year anniversary
of 9/11 s coming up and like think I
don't want to watch any of that I don't
ever want to see that footage again like
how the [ __ ] could you ever forget it
it's absolutely [ __ ] horrific
horrific I don't want to see it I don't
need to see it to remember it I'll never
forget sauer Pearl Harbor my grandmother
still doesn't like Japanese people
because of Pearl Harbor okay if she can
remember that [ __ ] I don't think I got a
problem member something 10 [ __ ]
years ago okay so now anyways total
total [ __ ] tangent there so I'm
watching this thing and for the first 20
just to warn Red Sox [ __ ] fans the
first [ __ ] 15 minutes of this movie
is the Bill Buckner thing the thing that
we left behind it's so funny because
Paul virzi just texted me than the night
before during the hurricane typical
[ __ ] Yankee fed typical Yankee fan
living in the past right he texted me he
goes hey Bill what was what was worse
for a Red Sox fan he goes Buckner or
Aaron Boone just out of nowhere we
weren't even talking baseball and I was
just like I was like neither dude it's
like I don't even think about that [ __ ]
anymore to be honest with you and then
he gets mad at me ah typical Red Sox fan
terrible [ __ ] answer blah blah blah
blah I don't know what he wanted out of
me so I just texted back it's like dude
I haven't thought about that [ __ ] since
2004 it's over you know what it is
it's Yankee fans used to be able to
bully Red Sox fans about that [ __ ]
because we hadn't won one forever you
know so they just I think that they miss
they kind of like our big brother who
just beat the [ __ ] out of us forever and
then one day we were the same height and
kicked the [ __ ] out of him you know and
then they just think it was over we're
not scared anymore we expect to beat you
it's [ __ ] over and I think they still
don't know what to do you know wait a
minute we used to tease you and we used
to always win and yeah now you don't now
you don't now we got this the biggest
joke of all [ __ ] time has hung around
your neck that'll never be beaten when
do you guys think another 220 million
dollar dollar team whatever the [ __ ] it
was with five first-ballot Hall of
Famers are gonna lose four games in a
row after being up three games to none
I'm asking you to a [ __ ] team that
has won a World Series in like a hundred
years right he had just asked me about
that and I swear to God I had not
thought about Buckner yeah since like oh
four it was [ __ ] it was over it was
great I don't even give a [ __ ] now I
don't even give a [ __ ] and I gotta tell
you it's phenomenal to sit down and
watch a Red Sox game and expect
something good to happen and when
something bad happens you get upset at
the player rather than some sort of
Specter or some sort of ghost or some
googly googly horseshit right so I'm
going to watch this [ __ ] thing and
all of a sudden out of nowhere this
showing I mean dude they broke they
almost broke down Bill Buckner more than
they broke down this poor Cubs fan and
in the end the dude doesn't get the
interview there's no interview they just
tell it but what I still recommend it
I'm still wrecking recommending it
because they show
they talk to the people some people I
guess they found the people who like
threw beer at him they talked to the
security guard it was removing him
giving him [ __ ] that he now feels bad
that he did and they have the footage of
him going out of the ballpark and
putting the jacket over him it's [ __ ]
amazing what happens to this dude
and I totally recommend it but I just
they should have been some sort of
warning for a Red Sox fan it was like
walking running into your old psycho
girlfriend somebody who stalked you or
something just somebody he just hadn't
even thought about mm for seven years I
haven't thought about that [ __ ] I
haven't even thought about that and
[ __ ] seven years and all of a sudden
this documentary about the Cubs they
just go blow by blow through the Buckner
thing cuz they they wanted to show how
Buckner was used as the scapegoat
despite the fact Bob Stanley threw the
wild pitch and now this kid was used as
the scapegoat for the Cubs despite the
fact that Gonzalez booted a [ __ ]
DoublePlay ball which would have got him
out of the inning I don't know it's it's
definitely interesting but I was I was
more than upset that and Elden they they
even show the Aaron Boone home run which
I don't even remember because that was
basically annoying for about twelve
months you know because it was
immediately rectified and but it was
just one of those things I don't know I
don't [ __ ] know but I got to be
honest with you I never really felt bad
for Cubs fans I never did because you
know they didn't have that anger did the
Midwest I don't know what it is they're
positive I don't know what it it's they
just didn't have that anger or misery
you know with the Red Sox back in the
day it was every Yankee success was our
failure and with the Cubs they just you
know hey let's play to zippity-doo-dah
was like a big [ __ ] keg party you
know it's like they didn't even give a
[ __ ]
even their curse was stupid the curse of
the goat it was just [ __ ] stupid made
no sense it's a ball park you got a goat
it doesn't belong here it's gonna [ __ ]
all over the place get it out of here I
curse you really any [ __ ] ways so
they actually bring up what like
scapegoating my sheep ruining this
entire thing you probably not have to
[ __ ] rennet they start talking about
what it's how they came up with that
terminology the scapegoat and it went
back to religion Oh gah that I guess
back in the day I don't know what the
hell religion it was they're all [ __ ]
stupid when you really get down to it
other than that do one to other stuff
that every religion has they would
basically have a goat they bring a goat
in I'm thinking all right they're going
to sacrifice it or whatever and they
wouldn't have the priests would lay his
hands on a goat for once instead of some
unsuspecting child
Oh a little molestation joke for you
how'd you guys like that huh do you like
that on your Monday do you think that
that was crossing the line well [ __ ] you
I'm stranded in New Jersey [ __ ] New
Jersey huh Jesus Christ what a bunch of
animals you don't amazes me about New
Jersey is how they still support
john-boy Jon Bon Jovi are the Bon Jovi
band to the point that that band can
sellout giant stadium still unbelief
let's Jersey for you 70,000 people
singing singing along lay your hands old
me your love is like bad medicine
Alouette Oni whoa
[ __ ] acid-wash as far as the eye
could see
dirty Jersey actually I think New Jersey
underrated is New Jersey it's [ __ ]
phenomenal all these New York snobs Paul
virzi being one of them I'm really
trashing him this week Paul versus your
typical New York snob and I hope you're
listening to this Paul
I hope when somebody sends this to you
yeah he's a snob he's one of those guys
who just thinks because he's on the
other side of an imaginary line that all
of a sudden I don't know what that the
trees are greener the grasses grad I
don't know what the [ __ ] it is you know
I really realize like most New Yorkers
judge New Jersey on their Drive to
Newark Airport where they go by all
those chemical plants look at it it's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh right despite the
fact that all some of the most major
celebrities live here we think they live
next to the plant you know all those
[ __ ] guys down on Wall Street the
children of the Illuminati they all live
out there in Red Bank with their [ __ ]
Rockefeller estates I know but they got
New Jersey license plates therefore it
must suck anyways let's get back to the
scapegoat so basically the you know the
priests would take a day off from
diddling kids and he'd lay his hands on
a farm animal and one would think he
would grab the horns and then start
fornicating but this that's another
story what they would do with with the
goat is he'd lay his hands on it and he
would basically somehow I guess after
everybody confessed to this douche bag
he would then place all of the sins on
the goat and then they would just banish
the goat and send it out of town with
all the sins and then everybody souls
were gonna be clean again but this is
the funny thing as the goat left people
would line up on either side of the
street and they would they would heckle
the goat in jeer at him and you [ __ ]
adulteress piece of [ __ ] yeah why don't
you jerk off again you [ __ ] just yelling
about the sins that they did I don't
know what it was yeah I keep stealing
from the pot at work you're selfish
prick yelling at a farm ill you know I
swear to god I would love to have a
segment on here of all this stupid
[ __ ]
things that that that they do in
religion that people you know there's no
[ __ ] way there wasn't somebody like
me back then going to this is [ __ ]
why are we yelling at a goat you know I
mean how do you you banged somebody's
[ __ ] wife you stole money from work
you know you booted an old lady in the
ass do you really think it's in the goat
now and it's just walking I just don't
[ __ ] get it even if they filled your
head up with it as a kid at some point
you got to be looking at it like this is
the [ __ ] goat it's got nothing to do
with it so anyways they were just jeer
at this thing and they send it out of
town and then everybody would be
absolved and I don't know where the goat
would go sometimes they say they take
the goat and they would throw it off a
cliff you know I know it's extra painful
for me because I [ __ ] love goats I
really do I was actually feeding son
this morning I don't know what it is
about him I think they're [ __ ]
hilarious you know I got this buddy
lives out here right it's got this giant
house there's all this [ __ ] land and
he's got farm animals farm animals on it
and I'm thinking he's got these [ __ ]
things because he's like me he likes he
thinks goats are funny or whatever and
it is and I found out that there's tax
laws out here that if you farm on your
land you only have to pay property taxes
on one acre so he went out and got these
goats he doesn't even give a [ __ ] about
him can you [ __ ] believe that he's
got like ten goddamn goats and he has to
go out there with this bucket of feed
every day
[Laughter]
he's got to feed these things and his
heart isn't in it that's what kills me
it's just just pay its just pay the
taxes if I it would be worth it to not
get up there with that lunch pail of
Cheerios every [ __ ] morning
jesus [ __ ] christ what is well it's
just money it's paper who gives a [ __ ]
you just you know work a couple extra
hours [ __ ] what do I owe you
you sit down you write numbers on a
piece of paper you stick it in a magic
envelope you'll [ __ ] lick it you send
it out next Jesus Christ he's gonna sit
there and have a bunch of goddamn
livestock this [ __ ] guy swear to God
if you had a Jarell what do you guys
want what do you guys want hang on this
is the hotel yeah sorry about that I had
to go answer the phone I couldn't even
figure out how to work the [ __ ] fault
it's probably somebody above me that's
probably yelling too loud god knows what
they'll mad about you know just think
about some of this [ __ ] I've made fun of
you know Jesus bestiality in Bon Jovi
you know they all hold the same weight
here in New Jersey the hell was I
talking about oh yeah this [ __ ] guy
swear to God if he if he we get a
giraffe he get like five giraffes if he
only had to pay like a quarter-acre tax
that was amazes me when people like that
in the money you know I mean I obviously
give a [ __ ] about money I want to have
enough to survive but the amount of [ __ ]
that didn't work and I never took it
back just blows my eye
I probably kept at least 25 grand with
his [ __ ] that doesn't work in my life I
just got you gotta be [ __ ] he see the
[ __ ] promise [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ] I
go off then my girl goes unless you
return it I'm not doing that [ __ ]
standing down there with the sales slip
like some angry old [ __ ] lady I'm not
doing it who that would be calling me
now I'm all self-conscious about
whatever if I'm too loud knock on my
door I swear to god I bet it was the Bon
Jovi [ __ ]
anyway so let's get on with the podcast
this is the Monday morning podcast
everybody if you're new to this podcast
welcome this is yes and if you're
thinking this is extra dirty and extra
angry this week no this is how it is
every [ __ ] week all right do one of
these every week I do them on Monday
mornings because I know most people hate
their jobs or they hate their commute
they hate their spouse or they hate
themselves you know and they need a
break and it's also a great way to [ __ ]
out wherever the [ __ ] I'm gonna be um
speaking of which I am gonna be in
Columbus Columbus OH Ohio at the funny
bone down at the mall not bragging on
the September 9th 10th and 11th that is
my next gig I'm gonna try to go to that
uh Ohio State game you know it's in
September that's always a dangerous one
you know to go to a college football
game in September who they play it huh
they playing Wentworth Technical
Institute you know I'm new to college
football over the last couple of years
and evidently that's what they do they
got all their cupcake games in the
beginning of the year and I guess these
other colleges they pay money to to play
these giant teams and get the living
[ __ ] kicked out of them on television
just to I don't know what to expose to
get TV exposure for their school I have
no idea
speaking of scapegoats their entire
[ __ ] division 3 team goes out there a
bunch of up against a bunch of roided-up
division 1 guys so whatever the [ __ ]
they're doing now I don't know and then
they get the [ __ ] kicked out of him but
I don't know every once in a while an
Appalachian Mountain State Community
College will be to Michigan so I don't
know who they're playing that weekend
but I'm gonna go down there
I was looking forward to it until I
spent [ __ ] 14 straight days on the
road but uh anyway it's the podcast
anyways if you want if you wanted me to
read any emails any questions you have
and you're underrated overrated send
them to bill at the mm podcast con if
you like to follow along on the podcast
go to WWE mm podcast com now a lot of
you guys keep just typing in mm
podcast.com and like what the [ __ ] I
can't find it it's the mmm podcast com
like the Ohio State University okay
that's what it is that's where all the
YouTube videos videos are that's what
you can contact me and all of that stuff
we have a donation button if you'd like
to donate any sort of money towards the
podcast we'd greatly appreciate it and
we also have the podcast select and this
is where I interview interesting people
I've only done one of them but I like to
speak of them as if it's a giant library
I got one then $0.99 there's a great way
to contribute 99 cents and he gets
something if you want to listen to NFL
football star right tackle Ephraim
Salaam talk about trying to rip
somebody's voice box out as they that
guy tried to [ __ ] break his arm that
interview was there and I will be doing
Monday morning podcast selects as I meet
interesting guests that's how I'm doing
them all right when somebody somebody
different okay because I don't want to
interview other comedians I just feel
too many podcasts are doing that I've
done too many podcasts talking about
comedy I don't have any comedy stories
left
I really don't and I gotta be honest
with you aside from a couple of people
who are really good interviewers the
Marc Maron's and Joe Rogan's and that
type of [ __ ] I probably should have
saved most of them for the unmasked that
I did with Ron from Ron and Fez I don't
know where you can find that but I did
one of those this past week and I just
been running my Yap all [ __ ] week
late why don't we get to something
entertaining here somebody sent me a
this YouTube video or this week you
really have to watch it okay it's one of
those shows it's basically it's a ripoff
of the view it's for broads sitting
around and they got you know the same
thing you know they got the older one
they got the sexy one and they got the
one who was fat and then got a [ __ ]
stomach tied up like a goddamn balloon
not now she's dropping weight faster
than a junkie right I don't know if
that's true I just looked around him you
know they got the racially mixed chick
and they all got on their [ __ ] shoes
right their little outfits I hang on a
second hang on a second somebody's
knocking I'll let you know what this is
all right you guys aren't gonna believe
this [ __ ] that was security and they
just said that they had they had a noise
complaint there was a lot of uh the guy
comes to I go to the door right this is
so pathetic that at 43 I'm getting
reprimanded I feel like I'm in [ __ ]
high school and I talk like it too
let me just the levels here or maybe
turn up yours because I don't want to
get kicked out of here and so I open the
door and there's a security guard and he
goes you been
and I'm like no because I know he I know
that he knows my name's bill but this is
the thing when security interrogate cyou
you never offer any information you know
are you bent now and then I just looked
at him like is there anything else I can
help you with and he's like yeah he
looks down on a piece of paper
oh are you bill and I was like yes
yes I am and he goes yeah we we got a
noise complaint from people on either
side of you these are VIP rooms on
either side of you and talking about a
it's very loud there's a a lot of
cursing and I'm like all right he goes
is there anyone else no wait wait he
told me can you step out in the hall and
I go for what because I need to step out
the hall and I said for what
and then he just goes into his spiel you
know what the [ __ ] do I need to step out
in the hall for am I gonna be able to
hear you better you know sit there
acting like you're a goddamn state
trooper with your [ __ ] sport coat on
it has the name of the hotel on the
lapel I'm supposed to step out in the
hall I don't know who you are right I'm
such a dick it's ridiculous right so I
made him basically say I just stood
N'Dour way and he asked me he goes is
there anybody else in there and I was
like no and then yeah that's what he
basically said that I'm being too loud
that Jesus Christ I was cursing I think
it was way
do you realize he said there's people on
either side trying to sleep and I was
singing
Bon Jovi songs at the top of my [ __ ]
lungs all right and I was also talking
about bestiality and I was trashing
Jesus you know what this hotels cool as
hell because when you really think about
it they probably should have kicked me
up alright so this is gonna be my voice
for the rest this is Bill on punishment
voice I'd like to apologize to everybody
here at the Sheridan anyways you know
what some rich [ __ ] on the other side
of the door the [ __ ] piece had one of
those really fancy glasses that they
think came from France but actually came
from a [ __ ] pottery barn if you can
hear me go [ __ ] yourself this is what
you get for nuking the economy alright
so anyways so I'm watching this show
these four [ __ ] broads on it okay
this is nothing to Ida B oh he told me
this is this is your one and only
warning next time you will be did he say
ejected from the hotel it's such hacky
security like terminology you know
[ __ ] I do you know how bad I just
want to yell [ __ ] at the top of my lungs
right now and get ejected from the
[ __ ] hotel just so I can get out of
Jersey maybe actually call up Paul virzi
and tell me do you know [ __ ] that that's
what I'm going to do after this podcast
I'm calling up Paul virzi and I'm out
coming down and get me all right you
know [ __ ] threaten me next time I
come up here what are you my [ __ ] dad
[ __ ] douchebag Christ I swear to God
you know it's funny about the male voice
is it is it carries you ever notice said
when there's a couple next door you can
never hear the woman's voice you just
hear the guy everyone smile go yeah you
never get abroad so I'm probably gonna
get kicked out what do I do now you
don't go [ __ ] yourself I'll take a cab
back to New York then the proper course
they probably won't show up because
they're still afraid afraid of the
Weather Channel anyway so these four
[ __ ] broads are on TV right and they
ended up there talking about that guy
that doing that story you know that
story where that dude got his dick cut
off I'm gonna have to raise the littles
here there we go
how's that is that better all right so
they're talking about that guy who got
his dick cut off his wife drugged him
tied him to a bed cut his dick off threw
it in a garbage disposal and turned it
on and it was basically because he
wanted to get a divorce from her but she
mutilated him she ended the guy's
[ __ ] life and he saw it quality life
is over and these women are talking
about it and lo and behold it's [ __ ]
hilarious to him they had all they could
do to keep a straight face during the
first minute of setting up the story and
then all the jokes come and they're
laughing their [ __ ] asses off it's
the funniest [ __ ] thing ever and this
right here it's because of that type of
[ __ ] that I don't feel that I am
misogynistic I just don't I think that I
am just like women I trash women the way
they trash guys it's just nobody pays
attention to the broad
they don't do you think if a guide
mutilated a woman in any shape or form
that four guys on a pregame NFL show
would be laughing about it you know
Sharon Osbourne was the guest and she
goes somebody asked you think the guy
deserved and she goes well it depends on
what he did you know I mean that thought
his totally overlaps the thought of
those morons in the Middle East who cut
women's glitz off you know it's [ __ ]
medieval thought and it's just
considered silly I don't know what it is
I but it maintains what I've always
[ __ ] said that women will do to you
exactly what they don't want you to do
to them if you let them and I think why
so many guys are miserable in marriages
is they get married too [ __ ] young
before they really know how to stick up
for themselves in a relationship and
that's why before you know it you're
married and all your [ __ ] is either in
the basement of the garage and she's
barely touching it and and you're
wondering what the [ __ ] happened to you
life you know I don't know the video is
it's gonna be up on the mmm podcast calm
you know something this is actually I
like this talking like this this is very
challenging to try and be funny with a
late night DJ voice all right this next
chunk of the podcast goes out to the
ladies ladies if you're out there and
you're single
hang in there there's a date rapist on
the horizon this next song raped me by
nirvana
it was out to all you [ __ ] I know
there's somebody some Vanderbilt on
either side of me going Keith Kersting
again anyways being on the road or did I
want to talk about [ __ ] laughing at
dick being cut off already talked about
that wanting to go home talked about
that
all right last week I was we showed that
YouTube clip about that guy running on
that soccer field and getting you know
getting beat down by the cops and then
the crowd overwhelms the cops and beats
down the cops and I wanted to hear from
the police officers to just ask
basically why they're such dicks when
they pull you over not in a judgement
that way but just I'm just basically
asking the question the way all drivers
talk so we have a cop responding here he
says hey built not all cops are [ __ ]
some are just lazy the summer after my
sophomore year oh no no this is a
different one where the [ __ ] is the one
from the cop that's the one I want to
hear oh here we go here we go here we go
let's see if I can read this before
being ejected from the hotel you know
it's gonna be the worst is if I do get
ejected this guy is gonna be standing
here but this security [ __ ] jacket on
in my hotel room watching me gather my
things so once again I already have a
game plan for that if I come if there's
another knock at my door I'm not opening
it I'm gonna look through the peephole
and I'm talking through the door so we
open the door please
I'm gonna go why because I'm just gonna
ask him straight out am i being ejected
from the hotel yes sir you need to let
me in and I'll just bolt the door and
I'm gonna be like listen I'm gonna
gather my things I'll be out there in
five minutes you just sit tight all
right you with no [ __ ] badge all
right what are you gonna do take off
your shoe is that what you gonna do try
and throw it through the crack in the
door it's not gonna hit me what a
[ __ ] [ __ ] can you step up to the
to the lobby into the hallway please
go [ __ ] yourself huh you're [ __ ] half
a cop you have a security guard like to
step out onto the hotel
now I won't okay then I'll just just
stay there then you douchebag
anyways let's plow ahead so here's a cup
okay bill the thing about this job is
basically that we have no [ __ ] idea
who we are dealing with at any given
time just because someone looks sweet
and innocent and just because the
situation isn't likely to escalate
doesn't mean that they're not capable of
murder or that the situation may go
pear-shaped quickly I don't know what
that means
pear-shaped I know in a shape of a pear
of shaped like what what shape is it
before it goes pear-shaped is it an
apple shape listen buddy you can't talk
shop because you're gonna lose me I'm
not that bright a guy anyways I can't
tell you how many times that someone
said to me like I'm gonna do anything
people or what about that person running
upstairs huh can you eject that eight
eight year old out of the [ __ ] hotel
all right you know I feel my feeling
right now like either I'm announcing a
golf match or I'm reporting live from a
hostage situation okay they're talking
to him right now
he still has the weapon up to the
woman's head you can clearly see that
she's frightening okay there's somebody
flanking him on the left oh he doesn't
like okay he's fired a shot it missed
and I'll they just took him down now oh
my god he's been shot in the head and
they have the woman um anyways here we
go plowing ahead here
so anyway seamount of time just got
pulls people over and the person behind
the wheel says like I'm gonna do
anything people think that I know oh the
people the drivers and stuff think that
I know them their whole lives and know
that they're capable that they're
incapable of harming anyone but I don't
I always think back to the Academy and
all the videos we watched of cops
getting killed or nearly killed because
they made one mistake or had a lapse in
the paranoia that keeps us safe
see that I knew it I know it was
something that they showed him at the
academy I said another thing to remember
is that there is a gun at every call and
every traffic stop the gun on my belt
no man is invincible and a lucky punch
can knock me unconscious leaving me
vulnerable to take to them taking my
weapon and killing me or others for this
reason we like to keep some distance we
don't like to be touched and above all
all we can't allow people to get the
opportunity to take control of our
weapon so when someone sir squirrely are
not listening to my commands they may
get cuffed and put in the back of my car
until everything is figured out they may
not like it but I am going home at the
end of my shift
not to the morgue that leaves another
point of control no one likes to be
bossed around and told what to do but
when the police are there were there for
a reason someone called us so we have a
reason to believe that we're needed once
we're there we have to be in control we
call the shots not not for go or to be
on a power trip but because if we lose
control we're [ __ ]
it's our ass if someone gets hurt in our
present and it's literally our ass if we
get hurt or killed if someone thinks
that they can do what they want or walk
over me how am I supposed to do my job
as for the videos you recently posted
those cops with the name changer were
absolutely terrible if there is a lawful
warrant for that guy's arrest
despite the reason it is their job to
arrest him the suspect knew about the
warrant I don't know what video this is
and didn't take care of it now he asked
to see a judge they should have just
they should have used much more force to
take him into custody but the reality of
it is you can't just be able to keep
passively resisting a cop until until
the cops let you go they can't let you
go all right here we go the video of the
stadium was disturbing they shouldn't
have been obviously jabbing the guy with
their batons but they had the right to
take him into custody
people running around sports fields
isn't and shouldn't be tolerated are
they supposed to stop the game and wait
for him to be finished with running
around what if he assaulted or killed an
athlete then everyone would be crying
that the cops didn't do anything there's
a great point
also when we deal with people 90% of the
possible danger from them is their hands
if you're laying on your hands and I
can't see them I will expect the worst
how am I supposed to do how am I
supposed to know what they are lay that
they aren't laying on a weapon when I
want your hand give me your hand
or I will use force to get them out then
there you go
one last thing is tasered they are
amazing tools I've been tased and
training and yes it sucks but it beats
getting thumped or shot we're in the old
days a guy may get the crap beat out of
him or his brain concussed now he gets
an electric ride for five seconds it's
also amazing because the suspect can be
cuffed while being tased basically less
chance for everyone to suit to get hurt
seriously hurt why should I risk getting
seriously hurt or killed going hands-on
with someone when they can just be tased
yeah you know what somebody told me a
long time ago if you want to make if you
get pulled over by a cop a great way to
help them relax and maybe bring down
them being a dick to you is have your
hands where they can see them you know
if it's during the day I always put them
like right on the steering wheel I get I
get pulled over a lot by the way not as
much I guess back in the day I did
because I used to just drive 80 miles an
hour
anywhere I was going you know there's
only so many [ __ ] farms you can look
at those funnies I'm still nervous about
getting thrown out of here and the only
reason why is because some of the roads
are washed out and I don't know where
the [ __ ] I would go but I don't know why
I'm nervous because I am now speaking in
a speaking tone if I'm not allowed to
speak you know this is actually great
stuff what if I show the hotel security
my hands maybe he'll allow me to stay so
anyways yeah I put my hands right on top
of the steering wheel where they can see
them if it's a sunny day I have one
hanging out the car window where they
can see and the other one I just put on
top of my head like an ape chilling out
in the Zook
you know when they sit there and they
just have that one arm draped over their
head I sit like that
and then when they show up I just have
my hands on the steering wheel and and
you know what there's still [ __ ] you
know it's kind of a crapshoot you know
so but I think this guy brought up a lot
of great points what the [ __ ] is he
supposed to do and that's a great point
if the guy ran on the field and did
something to an athlete then they would
blame the security and they would be
screaming and yelling at them you know
which probably goes back to the Weather
Channel that if they don't scare the
living [ __ ] out of people that they
would get blamed for not warning people
but I think it has more to do with
scaring people gives them great ratings
so I don't know any more cops want to
weigh in I here's one for you I want to
know what do you guys think about that
you can anonymously talk about this as
cops that kid who got shot on the subway
platform and died New Year's Day in
Oakland the dude definitely wasn't being
compliant he definitely wasn't giving
them showing him his hands and this guy
I don't know he's like The Manchurian
Candidate all of a sudden the guy said
the wrong thing the guy's laying on his
stomach one cops got his foot on his
neck I mean that the dude is down and
all of a sudden this one kid just stood
up takes out a gun and just shoots the
guy right in the back and I do it's like
what the [ __ ] you shot me and he ended
up dying you know what about that one
that that's that's one this is what I
should save for the podcast Silica's
that's what I want to ask and then I
want to like just have somebody go on
there anonymously and just say what you
think about it should that cop go on to
jail because he got what basically
usually happens when a cop shoots
somebody is he got off I don't know but
I don't want to I don't want to do this
whole cop thing
attacking cops I'd like to try to create
some sort of forum where you can
actually anonymously present your side
and not worry about pissing off other
cops
or worry about pissing off victims or
any that type of [ __ ] cuz I think it's a
now it's one of those things for some
reason I guess I know why the reason is
there's too much [ __ ] at stake so people
don't talk about it
that could have been a lot more fun
topic but I didn't have to speak in my
time out voice this is officially the
first mm podcast time out oh no wait a
minute then [ __ ] old bastard
downstairs you know something I think
I'm a loud [ __ ] I think that that's
what it is you know on both sides of the
country I've been told that I'm too loud
and I need to shut the [ __ ] up self you
know at some point you got to look in
the mirror and realize that you all
right let's plow ahead here
all right advice for the week bill I've
known this young lady for a few years
and we're very fond of each other but
she has had she's had she has a
possessive boyfriend with a stupid
haircut and a couple of times when she's
broken up with him she's come to me but
then she goes back to mackerel man this
is the thing that bothers me whenever
things have got gotten sexual between us
like I go down on her and blow her
[ __ ] mind
this guy has definitely got confidence
he goes she never returns the favor she
gets disgusted she even gets disgusted
if I sulk in my seat that I didn't get
any dude sulking is like I don't reckon
sit in an act like I know what turns
women on but I can tell you the exact
opposite of turning a woman on if you
want to have the exact opposite Spanish
Fly would be sulking nothing makes a
[ __ ] dry up like sulking just letting
you know right there okay but nothing
makes it wetter with complete
indifference anyways once she said
callously Oh after she did after the guy
went down her and then she didn't get a
[ __ ] she once callously said have a
wank to alleviate my horniness after
having her completely naked on my chair
worshipping her and pleasuring her holes
Jesus Christ buddy thank God I'm not
yelling
that one right there would have kicked
me out
uh it was just me with the Styrofoam cup
another time when we had intercourse we
were drunk she stopped me halfway
through and she even stopped halfway
through a doing you a favor [ __ ]
she's never made me [ __ ] these are all
the only examples of when she tried to
get me off and I'm a good-looking
chappie
so it's not that recently i boycotted
her body i said let's be friends to be
strictly platonic i won't even play with
her norc's i'm guessing that's her
titties this says this has had the
result of her trying to rekindle things
like the old magic if she's not that
into me what the [ __ ] is going on I'm
finished with her but any insights you
can give is a treasure all right first
of all dude you're not finished with her
just halfway through writing that you
probably realized what a SAP you were
being all right okay first of all who's
couldn't who you're you're [ __ ] with
a psycho all right and I don't this is a
very this is a very touchy one to talk
about here but this girl strikes me is
one of those girls who wants to be put
in her place and wants to be bent over
something and wants a guy to tell her
what the [ __ ] is what all right okay
consensually do you understand what I
mean
okay don't take this the wrong way go in
and just [ __ ] give him a forum give
her a forearm shiver right
I'm not saying to do that all right you
know some girls that [ __ ] and they know
they're a [ __ ] and they want to get it
to basically tell him that they it could
be this I have no idea but I could tell
you one thing right now sulking and keep
coming back for more you like Charlie
Brown she keeps pulling the football out
and you know if you want to [ __ ] this
girl walk away from her stop returning
her phone calls and all that type of
[ __ ] you you basically started to do
that when you boycotted a body but then
you said let's be friends that's a weak
move okay
what's this girl I think wants to see
you be a [ __ ] man
all right and you're not you're going
down on her you're pleasing her and
she's doing everything everything she
can to disrespect you and you're
allowing it and I think that's turning
her off and I think she's a [ __ ]
sadistic psycho so she's getting you off
she's leaving you with blue balls
you know I don't know that might be it
or she might be [ __ ] angry it's
something else and she's taking it out
on you
all I know dude is walk away from this
girl just walk away from her but if some
[ __ ] reason you still want to bang
her one more time
blow her off blowout for text center
calls for like a week and a half and
then randomly answer one and when you
pick up the phone just just have a
whatever vibe hey what's going on yeah
we're being returning my calls and me or
make takes yeah I've been busy what's up
you want to hang out now why not yeah
you know I don't know what do I want
handle you for I get blue balls you know
you're [ __ ] selfish you're [ __ ]
annoying leave me alone you know that's
probably too angry but just I'm sorry
guys I'm [ __ ] angry right now that I
have to talk like this yeah just blow
her off and just be you know and when
you go to meet her meet her in a public
place don't go over a place where she
can immediately she's gonna dress extra
sexy when you come over there because
she's trying to get that power over you
again meet her in a [ __ ] public place
and be talking to her as you kind of
glancing around the room you know sort
of hit on another girl while she's
standing there I'm telling you you know
and when she asked you to go home with
there don't just say I'm cool or
whatever you know [ __ ] blow her off
if she ever calls you again she wants to
hang out or whatever tell total to come
over your place and a second she starts
acting like a douche kick her out
I don't know I had shits it's
what sucks about a girl like that is
immediately you got to try to get into
her head then you got to start playing
games it's not worth it there's too many
decent girls out there who will when
they take the dick out they will [ __ ]
complete whatever you want so I would
just walk away from her let's be friends
Jesus Christ buddy that and sulking you
need to take those are the two parts of
your game you need to work on this
offseason alright and then maybe next
year you'll get the ring okay good luck
all right next one
bill I'm a cubicle dwelling suffocated
engineer in Texas I was rushed through
the college machine with all the rest of
the cattle destined to find a job Don
some pleated khakis and live the rest
live the rest of our lives and a
steadily paid servitude of the man but a
few years ago out of college oh but a
few years ago out of college and I hate
it I think you saying I'm a few years
out of college and I hate it I wish I
follow my desire to be some sort of a
writer and after listening to your
podcast among others and hearing from
friends that I should have I wish I'd
given stand-up a shot well now I'm 30
years old staring down the barrel of 35
more years as a cozy smug engineer
making six figures but hating five out
of every seven days of my life I don't
have any wife or kids but I feel like
I'm too old to jump back into being a
starving artist what do I do
yeah dude this is on you all right I
would never tell somebody who's got a
six-figure paying job to jump into this
[ __ ] awful business all right
but I would never tell you not to do it
all I got to tell you is you can't
half-ass getting into this business all
right
or you are gonna be you think you're
hating your life now just picture hating
five out of every seven days except
you're making [ __ ] you're making low
five figures and you're old now and
nobody wants to [ __ ] book you and you
don't have any wife and kids I'm telling
you all right
I'll give you this advice if you decide
to become a [ __ ] comedian there's no
turning back
alright and you got to go into it
you can't even consider quitting and it
has nothing to do with [ __ ] talent it
has to do with desire I'm telling you
that's what I would say so what I would
do if I was you I would keep my
six-figure job and I'd start doing some
open mikes that's what I would do all
right
and if you feel in your heart as you're
standing on stage that this is what the
[ __ ] you want to do with your life I
would do it in a second because six
figures seven figures if you're
miserable it's not gonna be worth it all
right but I don't know if you know
you're into comedy you know the way I'm
into playing drums drums are a hobby for
me I absolutely [ __ ] love them but
there's no [ __ ] way I would have what
was about to climb into a van with three
other [ __ ] guys you know any pasta I
what I'm not gonna do it yet just I
don't know I actually play drums and I
realized I didn't have it you know I
didn't I didn't have it as a musician
and I didn't have that Drive
[Music]
but when I got on stage the first time I
did comedy I just I never looked back
and I was just like this is I'm doing
this [ __ ] so there you go so you have to
answer those questions so the best way
to do it is to sign up for some open
mikes
all right see how it goes and see how
you feel and like I said if you feel
like that's what you want to do then I
would I would work towards it but I
would not quit that six-figure paying
job you don't just quit your [ __ ] job
you don't build up your time so you can
swing out of that job into some [ __ ]
paid gig so that's how I did it I kept
my day job until I moved to New York
City and I'd saved up a bunch of money
you know I had paid off all my bills at
an
car payment I had nothing and I moved to
New York and I had a nest egg of [ __ ]
money and and yeah I've told these
stories before I hate [ __ ] spaghetti
every goddamn night
three pieces of bread filled up my
stomach and I just did stand-up every
night and I just did I just wasn't doing
stand-up I was working towards getting
better at it
analyzing what I was doing wrong and you
know but I would never tell you to quit
your job and I would also never tell you
that you can't start comedy at 30 years
of age because you can alright so there
it is but it falls in your [ __ ] court
alright YouTube videos of the week we
had an earthquake here this past week
best earthquake reaction this is
hilarious it's like three guys on the
MLB network or something like talking
about baseball and all of a sudden the
hurricane comes it's [ __ ] hilarious
because people on the East Coast don't
know what an earthquake feels like so
they're sort of looking around like wait
a second is anybody else feeling
something moving in defensive them it's
one of those little shaken ones somebody
sent some home videos of Peyton Manning
as a kid running around whining or
whatever but uh I'm too hard on Peyton
Manning it's [ __ ] ridiculous how hard
I am on this guy but everybody wind is a
kid but if there's still funny as a
Patriots fan to watch and here's to that
I got it's called [ __ ] [ __ ] the police
one and this is hilarious this is some
guy I don't know if he's in Brooklyn or
what this black dude who knows his
rights has been harassed by the police
you can tell his entire life or whatever
but he's screaming at the cops that's
the mistake he makes they don't arrest
him but the [ __ ] he's saying if he would
just say it if he just said it I think
he would have been fine but he's
screaming it
and it's really funny it's actually this
guy it goes on for like 20 minutes and
I've said before it's all about lot not
losing your [ __ ] and this guy loses his
[ __ ] but I don't think he ever gets
arrested but it's [ __ ] hilarious and
here's a YouTube video of the week this
was actually suggested by Paul virzi
Will Forte and this is a sketch with
Peyton Manning Peyton Manning is [ __ ]
hilarious in this sketch
it's basically Will Forte you know
everybody comes walking in there like a
basketball team and they're getting
their asses kicked and well Forte comes
in and basically tells people that they
shouldn't quit and that he had a coach
and they played him this song one time
when his team was down by 60 points and
by listening to the song and amped him
all the way up and then he basically
puts on some [ __ ] song from the 1930s
and starts dancing to it and it's
[ __ ] hilarious underrated for the
week Will Forte guy is is [ __ ]
hilarious and please watch the
director's cut of macGruber
highly recommend that and what else do
we got here we got the woman cuts guys
dick off all the four broads laughing at
that and I got one other one here what
the [ __ ] is it hang on hang on hang on
[Music]
I'm the worst the [ __ ] did it go all
right no way don't say to love don't
curse too loud we will eject you from
the Sheridan our future gun owner Oh
creepy game show host there's another
one that we have creepy [ __ ] game
show host used to see this I can't
believe that this guy actually was
allowed on air and I showed it to Bobby
Kelly and he was laughing it just this
guy's [ __ ] the game show is basically
a mother and a daughter
you know something they already showed
this on tosh point-o i really try not to
do that because I figure everybody sees
it but we'll put it up there just in
case but Bobby Kelly actually showed me
another one I don't know where the [ __ ]
this took place it sounds like it's in
Scandinavia and this guy calls this kid
up to sing a song and he basically just
starts kissing
is back it's unbelievably disgusting
nibbling on his ear in the back of his
hair is this kid is singing it's [ __ ]
brutal and I overrated underrated for
the week and then I'm gonna [ __ ] wrap
this pot holy [ __ ] I learned 15 minutes
time flies when you're whispering in a
super8 overrated hand sanitizer I've
been sharing the company restroom with a
bunch of co-workers who believe using
hand sanitizer is the equivalent or even
superior to washing their hands with
good old soap and water it's not the
rubbing alcohol and hand sanitizer kills
the bacteria and destroys virus presence
on the hand and that's about it
it does not physically remove the
genital grime deposited on the hands
after a guy has finished jiggling his
junk to get rid of the last drops of
piss these people also use other
commodities such as the company and
refrigerator therefore effectively
covering every goddamn thing that they
touch with their dead penis and vagina
cells alright that guy is not short of
descriptive adjectives overrated lawns
people dumped all kinds of chemicals to
make them look pretty personally I
prefer clean water over a pretty lawn
overrated the overnight the other night
had decided to have a nice wank and
crash out for the night so I hop on the
generic porn site and started browsing
next thing I know two hours have passed
I was still awake hadn't wanked and
barely even had a Fleetwood Mac soft
rock half-chub etc I didn't even watch a
full video which I think no one really
does total [ __ ] waste instead I just
used the girls section of a Hurley
catalog I had laying around which worked
pretty well just so we all know all
right underrated paper grocery bags
plastic bags are given to you by default
and all the grocery stores I've been to
they should give you paper and if you
want plastic you should have to ask for
it
alright this ends the comedy the Monday
first Monday morning podcast comedy time
out and I feel lucky because I did not
get ejected from the hotel
that's it I hope you enjoyed this
weird-ass [ __ ] podcast this podcast
was like a Nirvana song started off loud
then it got quiet but never got loud
again so I guess it isn't it's like the
first oh shut the [ __ ] up alright good
[ __ ] saw just about let's see
[Music]